Speaker 1: Republicans are now accusing President
Joe Biden of bribery with absolutely zero
evidence.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE, Sean HANNITY, Chuck
Grassley, senators, members of Congress, right
wing media, they're all saying we might even
be getting to impeachment of Biden now.
Oh, what exactly did he do?
Well, we don't know.
What's the evidence?
Well, we don't have any yet.
Let me explain to you the back story of what's
going on.
Joe Biden accused by whistleblower of bribery
scheme with foreign nationals.
This is reported by Newsweek and many others,
a pair of top Republicans in Congress.
This is the base of the story.
A pair of top Republicans in Congress issued
a subpoena for records.
They say might, and the word might is doing
a lot of work here might detail a criminal
scheme involving then Vice President Joe Biden
and a foreign national.
The White House says it's unfounded and that
the claims are motivated by political bias.
When you look at who's at the center of this,
it's Iowa Republican Senator Chuck Grassley
and Kentucky Republican Representative James
Colmer.
James Colmer for months now, probably years,
in fact, has been saying Biden's guilty.
Of what?
Well, we don't know yet, but he's guilty.
And now they've got something.
They have an alleged whistleblower making
a claim that as of yet is completely unsubstantiated.
Now, they're going to they've issued a subpoena.
They're going to look for evidence.
And as I've said before, I'm going to speak
very clearly and slowly here.
If there is evidence to investigate, if the
investigate points, the crimes prosecute,
and if there is a conviction sentence that
applies to Joe Biden, it applies to Hunter
Biden, it applies to Hillary, Obama, Trump.
That is my perspective on all of this.
But we have to at some point say, do we have
any evidence whatsoever for what is right
now an allegation from a whistleblower?
The answer is no.
But that doesn't stop all sorts of the usual
clowns from coming out and saying it's time
we're going to impeach him.
Now, you might say, David, there really aren't
credible news outlets taking this seriously
right now.
And that's right, because there is no evidence
at this point in time.
So let's start with Marjorie Taylor GREENE.
She appeared on Lindell TVs.
Frank Speech, War room.
Yeah, I don't know.
She says we're getting close to impeachment
now.
Speaker 2: Well, this is where we are finding
true proof, linking Joe Biden, exchanging
money to make real policy decisions on behalf
of the United States.
It's pay to play.
This is a true crime.
And this was Joe Biden when he was vice president
of the United States, when Joe Biden took
a money payment from a foreign national in
exchange for policy decisions.
Speaker 1: Well, understand, there's no evidence
for any of this.
Speaker 2: He was vice president of the United
States.
This means that Joe Biden will be impeached.
The evidence that we've seen, we have cut.
Speaker 1: We have now understand there's
no evidence.
There's just an alleged whistleblower.
That's all there is.
Speaker 2: Out, out under covered in only
a few months, a few months time we were able
to do this.
Speaker 1: They've under-covered it.
It's not even a question of uncovering it.
Speaker 2: They've under-covered God for the
American people that voted that Republicans
in the majority and give us the gavel so that
we can have subpoena power to go after the
Biden crime family and everything they have
done to to sell out this country.
Speaker 1: Now, remember that Marjorie Taylor
GREENE was drafting articles for impeaching
Joe Biden before any of this stuff came out
to begin with.
And now they have something to latch on to.
Ted Cruz, of course, a bastion of sanity,
sober reasoning and and moral being, an upstanding
moral citizen.
Ted Cruz appeared on Sean Hannity's propaganda
program on Fox News, and they are also talking
about impeaching Biden without having any
evidence or substance whatsoever.
Speaker 3: From Grassley and Colmer.
And they're saying that they believe.
Speaker 4: The DOJ and the FBI possess.
Speaker 3: An unclassified Ph.D. 1023 that
describes an alleged criminal scheme.
Speaker 1: And they're not, by the way, alleged
as doing a lot of work here.
They're not even.
All they're saying is they have a whistleblower
claiming it.
That's all.
Speaker 4: Then Vice President Biden.
Speaker 3: And a foreign national relating
to the exchange of money for a policy decision
are that would be a high crime and misdemeanor,
which Senator it absolutely.
Speaker 5: Would.
In fact, it doesn't have to be a high crime
or misdemeanor because the Constitution specifies
that impeachment lies for treason, bribery
or other high crimes.
Bribery is explicitly noted there in the Constitution.
And I got to say, the evidence not only against
Hunter Biden, but the evidence against Joe
Biden being complicit and profiting from this
Corruption is growing and growing and growing.
Every week on my podcast, I have a verdict
with Ted Cruz.
I've walk listeners through.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that's a hell of a podcast,
by the way.
So they're talking about impeachment.
They've seen no evidence either past or I'm
sorry, Senator Josh Hawley not Pastor Josh
Hawley.
Senator Josh Hawley admits he hasn't actually
seen any of the evidence, but it should still
be up to Democrats to prove Biden is innocent,
which isn't exactly the way I remember of
burden of proof working in the United States.
Speaker 3: Senator, who do you think the other
country is?
We knew the Chinese connection and all that,
but this is a this is something new.
Do you have any.
Speaker 6: Information on that?
Speaker 1: No.
Speaker 4: I do not have any.
Speaker 1: Is it that and the funny thing
is, that's the answer for all of these guys.
I actually don't have any information, but
we definitely need to impeach Biden.
Speaker 4: Based on what the whistleblower's
has alleged in terms of the specific substantive
allegations.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 4: Other than that, there is documentation
that the FBI has.
And I just say again to those Democrats, they're
out there screaming about how Joe Biden is
innocent.
Joe Biden hasn't done anything.
Well, fine, Then show us what you know, show
us what the evidence is in the allegations.
Don't be afraid of what.
Speaker 3: The facts are.
Speaker 1: There you go.
So Josh Hawley making the case that he doesn't
have anything, but it's up to the Democrats
to demonstrate innocence, then Chuck Grassley
did also appear on Fox News.
Chuck Grassley is one of the main people here,
Chuck Grassley and James Colmer issuing the
subpoena here to the alleged whistleblower
for the allegations that they are making about,
okay, he is pressed about evidence and he
says, well, we have to wait.
Speaker 6: We're wondering exactly what this
is all about.
According to a press release that was sent
out by James Comey's office, this is the information
provided by a whistleblower raises concerns
that then Vice President Biden allegedly engaged
in.
Speaker 3: A bribery scheme with a foreign
national.
Speaker 6: It goes on to say the American
people need to know if President Biden sold
out the United States to make money for himself.
Senator Grassley and I will seek the truth
to ensure accountability for the American
people.
Speaker 3: Well, that.
Speaker 6: Really what's our appetite as to
exactly what this is all about.
Does this have to do with Hunter Biden's foreign
business dealings.
Speaker 3: Refrain or China, or is it something
else?
Yeah, well, I guess basically we've got to
wait to see what what the document and exactly
says Right.
But I convinced that we've got to get this
detail.
And at this time, the FBI needs to explain
whether it's accurate or not.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Did they learned nothing from the Dominion
lawsuit and the $787.5 million settlement
over on Fox News?
And then we have one from Newsmax as well.
Newsmax is very, very concerned about this,
as I'm sure you can imagine what.
Speaker 3: It says specifically the release
today, that the vice president may have altered
policy for money, a primary scheme.
He may have actually changed policy.
Have you.
Speaker 1: Narrowed.
Speaker 3: It down to what.
Speaker 1: Policies or at least tell.
Speaker 3: Me if you have what area, if you
can't see specifically, what do you know about
it, sir?
Congressman Fallon.
Oh, great.
That'll come out.
I think it'll come out very soon.
Speaker 1: Just like it's going to come out
with.
Trump's health care plan is my guess.
Speaker 3: Let's ask another question.
Very simple one What business, what product
or service did the Bidens ever provide?
Speaker 1: Yeah, there you go.
That's a real serious question.
So, listen, as I've said before, do you have
actual evidence against Joe Biden, Hunter
Biden, investigate?
Turns out there there were crimes.
It was legitimate charge.
Biden charged, Hunter Biden charged Joe Biden.
I don't care.
I don't care about defending anybody.
I don't care about cult of personality around
any of these folks.
If Bernie committed a crime charge, Bernie.
Okay.
It's been years of this stuff and the evidence
is just on the tip of our tongues, just beyond
the reach of our hands.
And yet it doesn't happen.
So I'm reminded of when I think of this whistleblower
I'm reminded of remember that I believe the
guy's name was Tony Bubba Linskey or something
like that, who was just going to deliver this
hammer blow of evidence against.
I don't even remember who it was.
It was going to clear Trump and all.
And then he was interviewed like twice on
Fox, and then you never heard from him again
because it was all completely bogus.
If you've got the evidence, let's see it.
But are they really going to do this for the
rest of Joe's Joe Biden's term?
The answer
is absolutely.
Yes, they are.